so my name is tom gingold and i want to
talk about a compilable markdown for
linear algebra that we call i heart la i
have the heart up there although the
text is small because some people say i
love la
some people think that la is los angeles
but it's it's linear algebra it's i
heart la is how we pronounce it but i
guess i shouldn't impose that on you
i'm
rebranding my lab a little bit i added
another two words computational reality
creativity and graphics lab the cr it
was hiding in there the whole time
and
i am interested in all kinds of creative
problems typically involving design
sculpting
drawing painting
geometry images occasionally singing
color motion and today
i want to talk about scientific
expression
so
sharing scientific ideas often relies on
written communication this could be in
the form of an email that we write to
each other with an idea we could write
on a chalkboard or a whiteboard uh we
could write and publish an article a
blog or a scientific paper
and uh just to
to to look at this uh let's look at how
we consume this kind of thing in
computer graphics
that's an area that i work in often
and so let's say you're a student you
want to evaluate an idea you find a
paper you read this paper over and you
look for the formula and you're going to
implement this formula so here we find
this formula and we want to implement it
in c plus plus
so we read the math
we have enough experience to know how
this math should be translated into code
we write the code
and uh when we do this it's easy to
introduce a bug that we might not notice
right i got the index wrong that i
should be a j
and that's going to be a subtle bug to
um
to find later
we might work with somebody else or we
want to do an implementation in a
different language like python so then
we rewrite the same thing in python
and this translation between the math
and the code and the code somewhere else
it's tedious it's error-prone it's also
redundant because people all over the
world may be doing the same work they
may be implementing it and repeating the
same work and it's
you know introducing different bugs they
think your technique doesn't work they
haven't even implemented it right
and then this is also
tragic because
math
with the right context always has an
unambiguous interpretation
at least according to mathematical
philosophers and linguists
and even worse
the formula in the paper sometimes have
has a typo so here's an example where
this is a typo that was published right
because the math
is
uh
is not executable
so let's look at the flip side how do we
how do we write math how do we
how do we write these scientific
articles so mathematical notation has
evolved over the centuries this is an
excerpt from a table on wikipedia it's a
really awesome table you can see some
you know there's some nice texts and
talks about uh mathematical notation but
we can see like the plus sign uh dates
to the you know 13
uh 1360 approximately um
we're considered to be in the symbolic
stage of math we're out of the
rhetorical and syncopated stages of math
where a lot of math was conducted with
just rhetorical arguments
we have a lot of symbols and we we use
these symbols
and you know a lot of the ones we
recognize plus minus parentheses you
know equal sign multiplication you know
they get worked out from 1300s to the
1600s and then you know summation and
and uh and then the linear algebra stuff
actually a lot of it comes and sets come
a little bit later in the 18 and early
1900s
so it's it's not really it's not correct
to say that this this notation has been
fixed for centuries it actually you know
a lot of it's fairly recent
but it is well established at this point
uh now if we want to write this math
digitally you know we have to uh get
this into a computer so to do that we
rely on markup right so here's here's
latak right here's la tech or tech
for those symbols and some of them right
the ascii symbols the ones that are on
your keyboard easy to type uh they're
they're you know they're they're there
um but a lot of those other symbols have
this markup and
the output is what we just saw but the
input is obfuscates those symbols
um
we saw a trend in the mid-2000s of
lightweight markup languages like
markdown which codified these like
pre-existing conventions people did when
writing like text like not math but text
like if i'm writing an email to you and
i want to bold and i want to emphasize
something maybe i'd put some asterisks
around the word right and so that like
that was uh
that's what you know that's what they
looked at and marked out and said what
are these conventions why don't we just
promote these conventions into
you know into proper html tags and so
you're getting mark up out of uh
existing conventions
what i'm showing here
somewhere around that same time um
ascii math by peter gibson
had a sort of similar idea let's do math
without as much markdown
just
find something that we can parse but
some of the choices are a little bit you
know unusual i don't know anyone that
would write xx to get a proper
multiplication sign
not too around that same time right
unicode's been invented and so we can
just lean on unicode and we can write a
lot of math in plain text
uh
and the someone actually proposed a
unicode based lightweight markup
language in
2006 um
which is kind of interesting you you
write what you see there what we see
here is what you do so long as you can
input the unicode unicode entry is
actually not that hard anymore um in
emacs there's tech mode and vim there's
digraphs on on my mac i just go into
system preferences and set up a bunch of
text replacements so you know unicode's
out there and unicode can give us nice
looking math but this math is is dead
math we haven't solved our executability
problem
we can type math but we can't it's not
doing anything for us
so that's that's what we uh we set out
to to look at here um we
so that's that's the that's this
iheartla project and this is joint work
with yong li i was a phd student of mine
shui kamil and alex jacobson and i
really want to
make yong's picture big here for a
moment because yong is my phd student
who's done
like
all of the work that i'm showing you
today i'm really just up here talking
about yong's work so i'm deeply indebted
to
yang
and
want to credit him appropriately
so let's look at let's look at what i
heard
what i heard looks like so here's i
heard la
and it's a language with syntax that's
designed to closely mimic conventionally
written linear algebra while still
ensuring an unambiguous compilable
interpretation so you write a linear
algebra
in text form in plain text and then we
compile this we take this and we compile
it
uh into
tech so it can you know look
more presentable
but we also take the same text and
compile it into c plus plus or python or
matlab and potentially other backends in
the future
so to kind of put the space of different
languages out here so we were irlay
combines this conventional syntax with
unambiguous execution so those are two
axes and we can you know draw a diagram
and plot things right and you know all
programming languages they have
unambiguous execution so they really
just stick there up at the top right but
uh
you know you look at the math written in
in c plus you know
and it's does not look like conventional
linear algebra
right you go farther to the right with
like matlab and julia they look a lot
more like uh conventional math syntax
and fortress and mathematica but we're
trying to be as far to the right as we
can so it really just looks like what
you would type if you weren't thinking
about you know compilability if you were
just trying to communicate the math
um
you know latte tech and ascii math are
don't have unambiguous execution so
they're you know they they look like
they could they may they may look a lot
like
conventional syntax but they're they're
just not compilable
um
yeah
i'm not plotting up here some languages
which aren't about linear algebra like
agda lean and [ __ ] they're like uh uh
about derivations but a lot of them lean
into this unicode and math looking
syntax so that's not we're not the only
ones to do that but uh but we're doing
it in this this executable math space
okay so to set about you know trying to
compile and execute math uh you know we
have to decide like what we have to
understand what are people doing like
what are the conventions in mathematics
because although any mathematical
formula has an unambiguous
interpretation there a lot of context is
needed to understand what the authors
were
you know were intending right so once
you once you know what the what the what
the conventions of their symbols are you
can interpret their symbols and
ambiguously but you need to know what
the conventions of their symbols are and
that does differ in different subfields
of math
there's um
there's a very nice
math overflow post by uh terence tao who
goes into
10 or 15 different notations for just
writing you know a dot product right and
they're using different subfields of
math so the the the
um so we picked the subfield and it's
the subfield that
that we often work in which is computer
graphics and so we looked at
all the numbered equations in siggraph
2019
and some of the unnumbered equations so
it's you know we generated this big body
of about 2 000 equations
uh and then analyze them we categorize
the things we're seeing in these
equations to know what you know what
what what's important and what what
shows up all the time so
here's you know here's some uh here's a
breakdown but i'll go into this
so the the first one to look at is
single letter variables so 98 of the
equations are using single letter
variables which is like when programming
you know i often got that uh
hammered into me that we should not use
single letter variables right
we're encouraging long and descriptive
variable names
but that's almost unheard of in
conventionally written math
and
you know
we can discuss the reasons why this is
uh we may not know the reasons why this
is i mean this is up to the authors
authors are making this choice but this
you know this is like a clearly
established convention
it probably has to do with you know the
fact that there is prose around the math
which is explaining the symbols and that
once it's time to look at the symbolic
formulas uh the what we're trying to you
know what the what the authors are
trying to convey with these symbolic
formulas is you know conveyed
by what's happening with those symbols
and so the symbols themselves are just
you know hopefully you can keep them in
your head and then make sense of what
the operations are
so here are some examples of that
but one thing that that lets you do with
single letter variables is uh prevents
ambiguity during multiplication which is
done typically without any operation
between them you just put two letters
next to each other so that would be
confusing if your variables had multiple
had were made up of multiple letters
so that's that's one thing that you
avoid but it's something else that we
see
uh yes yes
did you track how many uh use these
descriptive subscripts like the task in
isp in the top left that's something
i've used before but i don't know how
common it is right i don't think we have
data uh on on that specifically yeah not
specifically yeah yeah that's but but we
do notice that like these you know
decorations are very common right so not
just the subscripts but also you know
over bars and um
uh you know arrows and hats and you know
all these kinds of things so people are
decorating these things uh although
these hats and these you know the
subscripts and these arrows those are
those are you know those are different
role than than if you make a subscript
which is text which make a subject which
is text you're basically you know
inserting a long variable name and
that's true and that's true
yep
uh but so okay so let's let's look at
you know
the rules we we just we know we chose
for variables in iheartla
so here's uh here's some you know here's
a little bit of i heard la
and um
uh we encourage single letter
identifiers right we we also encourage
um you know unicode
decorations um
this actually has uh implic so just we
get justification as multiplication we
we do that we really want this to look
like math um this is implications
implications for the compiler design um
and i'll talk about that a little bit
later
um but the you know with unicode leaning
into unicode we can get you know lots of
expressive variable names with you know
these text decorations and
uh you know as i'll argue we shouldn't
be so scared of typing unicode on our
computers you know we're typing emojis a
lot now uh so you know we should also be
typing unicode
um for you know long and ambiguous names
we we also have you know a mechanism
where if it would be ambiguous you know
we we went with uh backticks like
markdown did
but uh they actually don't need to be
used all that often in iheartla
um something else that that we
you know
a choice that we made that variables
can't be redefined this is you know in
mathematics in programming people
science have this like what does the
equal sign mean in programming are we
assigning or are we you know doing
equality and you know if if we're doing
a qual if you don't if you can't
redefine a variable this distinction
sort of evaporates
right it's like the the your your def
you know you're defining x is equal to
this thing and we don't x can never be
equal to something else so that
distinction goes away it's just we can't
redefine variables and
and and so we don't need to you know we
don't need a different symbol for
assignment versus equality
uh and something else you'll see here is
that we you know we have to have a type
system since we're going to be compiling
this we have to have types and
so we have this type system and then you
know we we can the compiler can do a lot
of checking of what you're doing and
tell you if there are dimension
mismatches and
and we can do this at compile time just
statically check is this can you
multiply these matrices or not
so let's look at matrices a little bit
more this is uh this is
this is like a syntax we have for
matrices so you don't need commas
you know you you just put what you want
in the space that you want it
so that's it on the top left let's look
at this example in the top left so we
have in the in the diagonal we have
a and k in this case are scalars so this
is a two by two matrix
uh l is just a normal two by two matrix
uh on the right we see in the um counter
diagonal we see you know m is being used
in x and y and those are you know
matrices and vectors so this is a block
matrix and uh uh
the identity matrix
and the zero matrix are getting
automatically you know lifted to be the
right dimension because there's only
there's only one correct answer that can
actually make a matrix for this you know
using these blocks the identity matrix
has to have you know the same number of
rows as m
uh and has to have the dimensions as the
number of rows is m and the zero also
has to have this you know the same
number of dimensions as uh
the rows and columns of those blocks
that it's adjacent to so
uh the same syntax gives us you know a
nice way to input these matrices
uh and we can you know we also have uh
notations for sparse matrices so you see
you know mathematics you can write these
underscore and
l underscore i j and we're defining the
entries of i and j and again with single
letter variable names
we don't even need a comma you know
between the i and the j
so we get this you know syntax which you
know
is uh
that we're pretty happy with
um so over here you know the dimensions
of l is determined by the dimensions of
m
and on the right we're defining a sparse
matrix uh and it's you know got a
conditional and we don't know how big l
is we don't we don't know how many zeros
it might have you know on the right or
on the bottom so we you know the author
does need to say what the total size of
l is
okay um something else that a lot of
equations use is you know functions that
are not defined in the paper so we have
to have a way to talk about externally
defined functions
um here you know here's some formulas
that show up and you know here's like
examples of these functions which you
know show up everywhere right
these expressions don't exist in
isolation so
some of these functions are just well
known
like trigonometric functions so sine
cosine and other trigonometric functions
those are just like you know you expect
them to be there
so we allow people to just pass in
functions and all the languages we
support you can pass in these functions
and you have to you know provide a
mathematical type annotation for them
but then you can use them
and we also have some built-in linear
algebra and trigonometric functions that
you can make use of
summation summation is uh is kind of an
interesting case of a mathematical
operation so in papers we often see
summations that have you know implicit
range
you know ranges so there's there's
nothing saying where to start and stop
iteration
um summations can be nested right so
double summation summation inside of a
summation
um
and they can be part of larger
expressions
um and
summation doesn't enclose the thing it's
summing over with a parenthesis or with
a bracket or with anything right so we
have a choice to make here it's kind of
ambiguous when should you stop summing
um so
you know to to make this really clear
here's you know it's
what seems to be a simple summation
but there's two interpretations are you
summing just the uh ai and the bi or are
you also summing up a bunch of copies of
c
and this could be arbitrarily complex
you could have a second summation to the
right
uh so you know to to make a decision on
what to do we looked at what are people
doing right so we want to be compatible
with what people are doing so we looked
at um
examples you know
in wikipedia and again in siggraph and
here's a bunch of formulas you know from
sugar 2019 and when you when we look at
these formulas we see most of them are
taking the the conservative summation uh
choice so they're they're
they are putting parentheses if they're
summing over more than just one
parameter um other than these two
so uh with this conservative summation
we seem to match what most people are
doing and that seems to be like the
reasonable trade-off space that with the
trade-off space that we're happy to
happy to exist in
so which is to say we take this upper
path
and you know infer bounds from use so
you get to write your summation
and uh because w i and and ti uh appear
here then the summation is going to
iterate over all the elements in in that
thing
and hopefully eliminate some mistakes in
papers where people got the summation
bounds wrong
in their summations
okay so
norms also show up a lot in fourteen
percent of the equations and this is a
bunch of different kinds of norms l2
norms so squaring things
l1 norms
frobenius norms of matrices
nuclear norm occasionally shows up
vector norms with matrix subscripts
so
we can you know we can support all of
these put all these in
uh and just support
all the norms we can find
so let's look at the the compiler right
so that's that's like that's like an
overview of most of the the pieces that
we support and uh the compiler you know
starts with some iheartla source but in
this example right here
if we you know we do our first pass on
this compiler and we can you know look
at all the terms and the symbols but we
need a second pass and the reason we
need a second pass is we need to know
what the types of things are
in this case this f of x squared if f is
a function then we should be squaring
the result of the function so the square
should happen after
we put f of x together in a node but if
f is not a function if it's a like a
scalar then we should square x first and
then multiply it by f and this you know
we'd have to have a too fast design
to do this
we also need this you know when we take
in
external functions like sine and cosine
those aren't single letters if the
anytime the user does define a
multi-letter
symbol we also
detect all of that in the first pass the
first pass is just parsing out all the
symbols and what their types are and
then the second pass can correctly um
build a correct abstract syntax tree
and then you know we do code generation
right so we've written the c plus which
is a static language we've done python
which is a dynamic language those are
both the zero indexed we've done matlab
which is a one indexed language uh
you know we've done latex because we
want
the same i heard la to be used
authoritatively to generate the
equations that you put in your paper and
then also you know the
the code that you can that you can
distribute that everyone can run and try
uh and you know we want to extend this
to other languages in the future
so let me do a live demo
let's see how big that is that that's
that is probably not readable
that's readable but is that readable
either we go with this or we go with
this
but then we you know we lose that we
have to scroll to see the uh you know
the beautiful version of it
um yeah so this is an example here's a
you know here's a matrix right this is a
column vector and you can see you know
we're using um
uh you know the this the unicode
superscript seven you know which we can
type
uh you know
you know any superscript we want it's
you know do text replacement uh i really
i really am passionate about the point
that it's not so hard to type uh to type
unicode into a computer
um
and you know you can use this symbol for
multiplication of two you know two
numbers um so this is a uh you know we
compile this and we get you know compile
succeeded you can copy any code you've
got as a url send it to a friend they
can paste it in and you know they get
back exactly the example that you had
just typed so it's you know pretty easy
to share
and you know you can just scroll down
here and just copy and paste out you
know the output from any language that
uh that we support
um
let me type let me type in some more
examples all right let me do uh let's
let's implement let's implement dot
product right so
let's do a summation
over i
of two vectors a i and bi
so let's say a i
is
real num is a real let's see how long is
this vector let's say it's an n vector
and let's say b i
is
let's say it's an m vector so this
shouldn't compile right because we have
different different dimensions i really
hope this doesn't compile
right and we get an error the dimension
mismatch right can multiply an n and m
vector together
uh
but if we correct the type we say
they're both dimension n and we compile
it and we get
no that's oh right i'm sorry okay
uh each element of a and b is a real
number
so
that works
this is awkward
uh
yes this is i'm defining uh the
syntax i'm defining the elements of a
sequence if i wanted to say that a is an
uh n vector i would have said i should
have said that and b is an n vector and
then this should compile
as well
okay so we have sequences it's not
always easy to write math folks
sometimes we make mistakes when we write
math you know but at least we have a
compiler now that's going to be catching
our mistakes and telling us when we're
doing something that we didn't expect to
do this is a teachable moment right i
just tried to multiply like scalar
multiplication two vectors right and
and you know if i really wanted to
multiply two vectors i should have put
in like a dot product right and said
okay each element of a i and bi
is an n vector and then this should
compile as the sum of the dot products
yes i saw some hands yes in this case
so it's going so in uh it is defined by
the input by the input length so if we
scroll down to the code um
let's look at the python code so we can
see that it's um it's summing over the
length of b whatever that is
right like we we have not defined the
length of the sequence it's like it's a
it's a dynamically these are dynamically
sized sequences
is that the well i guess like it makes
sense that if a and b were vectors and
you did a sum over i of a sub i then it
understands that i is indexing over n
yes yes
it doesn't
it doesn't make i guess it's not obvious
to me how you would pick some sensible
value of i here
right so you know at some point this has
you know this gets converted to you know
to code right so in let's say in and you
know
c plus plus you're passing in a vector
right so at that point right the code
can
uh get the size of the vector and
iterate over that size
it's you know it's it's a it's it's just
it's a sequence of you know some
indeterminate but you know indeterminate
like of an arbitrary size that
is general to the length of that
sequence
if so if a ibi were just reals and then
you were just doing multiplication of
them
it still picked a value of i what was
that
so yeah that's right in this case yeah
and then a i and bi are both reals
it's still pick a value of i right
right right this is yeah so let's start
with this one this one you know this one
if we look into c plus plus right we've
got a vector uh of doubles for a and b
right we they they must be the same size
because
uh the elements are real the elements of
the vector are
it's not it's reals still it's changing
the interpretation of them like these
are still elements okay right right
because of the subscript on the left
hand side
right right
yes
we would love to do that the inverse
problem right go over all the all these
code implementations and factor it into
linear algebra and then yeah that's i
mean that we would love to do that
um we can't do that i don't know how to
do that and that's not unannounced
future work uh work that we've already
done
yeah yeah
your initial assumption was we used to
write maths for the
but now it's like i have to write mods
on a computer again so
maybe on your first point that you're
not an expert in computer vision maybe
that part could help you know you write
the math you convert from that language
to maybe this can be the translation
model
yeah i think you know i think something
that's uh that's uh you know
a little a little more doable so there's
like programs like math picks right and
they they'll you know you can take a
picture of math and they will give you
lot tech for it right and uh so that's
going from math to a lot representation
of math which is ambiguous right but if
if it's like a subset of latex that's
you know we can convert to i heard la
right that would be a pathway that i
think would be
you know
famous last words not too hard
right but that i think that would be you
know a pathway to do that but going from
like code right which is
you know
where the the semantics you know of the
data you know the types the high level
types the linear algebra types have been
lost and you're just taking in you know
vectors of doubles um that's
you know that would that would be great
that would be great i mean there was a
you know i think the halide folks did it
recently and they have this like metal
lift system which they've used to you
know take like adobe's code base of c
plus plus and like turn it into halide
and they can recompile you know for new
uh architectures and you know that's
like production strength so it seems
like the you know the technology is uh
uh
it seems like it's worth you know i'd
love to do it yeah
is there another question before i go on
okay okay
um
let's see another
demo i should give you well this is you
know maybe this is this will some of you
will enjoy this uh so this is a case
where you know we have three different
matrices and again we're going to check
the types of these matrices are
compatible you know for multiplication
um you know if i make this 5 by 5 right
we're going to get an error that the
dimensions mismatch um but one thing
that's you know
that i'll point out is in a static
language like c plus plus you know i
don't know if any of you have used you
know eigen but in eigen it's it's very
easy to make an arbitrary dimensional
matrix and then the memory is you know
dynamically allocated and iterated over
you know with dynamic loops
but if you give it
proper static matrix dimensions
i think it can do stack allocation and
it can you know generate a compile time
it knows you know the loops it should do
and so the code would be more efficient
and it's very tedious to do as a human
right but you know this we have um
a compiler here that can do all this for
us right and so it can you know put in
the exact type uh dimensions and also
the output dimension so um
we i should say we we really are not
interested in uh
high performance high efficiency code
here i mean that's been a non-goal i
wouldn't say we're not interested in it
we would love it but it's it's you know
our goal is is not to say this is the
code which uh which you know is
production is production ready it's as
optimized as you know we hope to to be
able to do
there's a lot of work out there on
highly optimized linear algebra and
tensor math and you know people doing
a lot of work in that space you know we
want to generate something which is like
you can evaluate the idea and decide
whether it's worth putting additional
resources you know into
into doing like a faster you know
uh implementation
but
you know there's potentially a nice
inter interaction there where you know
we can output this linear this linear
algebra
uh intermediate representation and
interface it with these other systems
which are doing high performance stuff
and you know and get and get i don't
know maybe the best of all worlds
right i want to show another example
here i've shown some sparse matrix
things but
i want to show
this example this one points to
something which
so this is uh the matrix form of
evaluating a bezier curve let's pretty
these up
let's do let's get more unicode
right so this is the matrix form of uh
of evaluating a bezier curve at an
arbitrary point along the curve t for in
any dimension right so this is this is
uh it's a cubic bezier curve so we have
our t cubed t squared t and one here's
the matrix of coefficients every
different cubic
spline or every different cubic
curve has a different matrix like this
so you change these numbers around you
change the meaning of what the control
points are giving you
um i'm bringing this up because this you
know shows that uh we have this 2d
you can make 2d matrices but we don't
have a solution for where the line i
mean the line continues at the end of
the matrix right it'll be really nice if
like p could be up here
you know
so if you had like another big matrix
right if you wanted to put another
matrix
uh this is no longer doing what i said
but you know put another matrix here
right like this the the the math really
starts to bleed out bleed onto onto
multiple lines and we don't have a good
solution for this this is just you know
we consider this the the
i don't know this was the trade-off we
came up with for plain text math you
know in a linearly encoded text file
like non-linearly encoded you know math
is very interesting and if you have
ideas about that you know i'd be happy
to talk to you about that
um
yeah couldn't you define each of the
matrices as a variable and then just oh
yes absolutely right right we could just
say you know um
i could just say m equals you know this
right and then
right right and then this is just now
you know
mmm right
here let's just make this like that
right and whoops symbol
all right that's out of order
which we now we it's not in this online
version but we do
because we have us because we have the
single static assignment where you in
our current in the non-web version that
we've done you can actually put things
in an annual order and it just figures
out the right order
but that's not in this demo right so
yeah so this this this compiles right
and this is you know this is nice on the
same line we could square this
um right right but you know it's uh i'll
let me switch back to the the slides and
i'll show you some other examples and we
can
we'll see how this comes up sometimes
when converting formulas that are out
there
so you know we want to evaluate this
right we we came in saying okay we've
got this we looked at math we can
compile math uh and
you know we wanted to know what
conventions people were doing and we
want to know if we've succeeded right so
to know if we've succeeded we don't know
if it's if it's you know if it's useful
right and so one of the ways to know if
it's useful is to collect a you know a
variety of examples from in the wild
right so just collect a bunch of
examples which show the breadth of the
kinds of things we can do and so you
know for each of these examples you know
we can we can we have a gallery right
and and you can compare the math this is
a screenshot from the paper this is the
the math that you know we write in
iheartla sometimes there are some small
differences um
but we try to minimize those if we've
succeeded we've minimized those i would
argue
um and then you know for each of these
examples we can you know you can go
browse around in our pages and see you
know the c plus plus and the python and
the matlab code and all of this
and let me zoom in on a different
example
this is unplanned
where is it right this example down here
at the bot oh you're not saying this
because this is unplanned
right so this is an example where
somebody wrote a very long uh
a very very long equation right and then
you know and i heard a lay it ends up
kind of spanning three lines right i
would argue this is fine um
i think one of our uh
reviewers thought this was uh that the
input equation was like the problem you
know this was a sort of pedagogical
punishment because this comes from a
course for students to make students
have to read something so long but
that's that's an example where that
comes up you know
is just having to just end up spreading
across multiple vertical lines
so another way to evaluate whether we've
whether we've succeeded right is to uh
um to take the output code that we
generate yes
it's interesting so have you thought
about line breaking
in appropriate places like
it's probably worse to line break
between two variables that are being
multiplied
rather than
you know other places yeah so the only
line breaks we had there were in 2d
matrix definitions
right so if you put a line break
anywhere else you're
you know you're exiting you're ending
the the statement
right that's that's so it's these 2d
matrices where we want to have a nice
you know beautiful 2d arrangement no you
know no commas no semicolons you know we
do actually support um like semicolons
if you want to put it on one line that's
a choice that matlab does but i mean i
don't even like that we support it you
know because it you know i don't want
things to look like
weird matlab you know
programmy math i want things to look
like you know like math like you would
like you would like like
like you would want to write it with
without constraints you know given like
a chalkboard or a 2d you know 2d writing
surface
but you know with the just parsing two
we thought about like okay you could put
closing bra you know closing breaks you
know closing brackets on each one there
actually are unicode symbols for the
like all sides of a matrix so you know
upper upper left bottom right you know
upper right bottom left and then like
vertical bars so uh you could
potentially do something there where you
go okay well that's that's a top right
that an unclosed you know matrix so it
must continue
down um but it just starts to get messy
in it it's you know the trade-off feels
like um
uh
yeah i we didn't pursue that far enough
to know whether it's like
there's like an
you end up with something that works
nicely and you know
uh so another way you know we want to
evaluate this is to see if we can
integrate with with existing code take
our code see if it's useful you know so
so we went to you know found a bunch of
papers uh and that had code online
right and these papers you know produce
these pretty pictures and then we went
to we want to
simulate
using i heard la in the real world so so
uh
open the paper find a formula
take that formula write it in iheartla
take the output code replace code
in this example you know find the find
the find the paper find the formula
replace the find the code in their code
base find the replace write the formula
and i heard la take our output code and
put it in the formula so let me like
simulate that right so here is somebody
who wants to implement this paper right
so they you know they're reading this
paper they say okay there's this formula
in the appendix and i want to take this
formula and you know i want to try it
out so they find the formula
which is a simple solution for this
constrained squares problem
and they go and they open the you know
here's the formula
they open the iheartla you know editor
and they uh they start you know they
they have their code base they have a
space for it but they need something to
put in to fill in here
and they have you know the input
parameters are all prepared we just need
you know an implementation of this
formula
so in this case these those subscripts
are like not actually subscripts they're
like decorative subscripts so that's one
place where the backticks uh end up
getting used to just not telling her
delay that we're defining
sequences to just tell these are just
like parameters with weird names
or with subscript names
and you know you get the code you find
the code you go and you you know paste
it into the right place
compile it you know launch the program
you know open the mesh
and then you know solve the solve the
equations
and get your instant field aligned mesh
using code generated from iheartla
and we verify that we get the same thing
that the paper the implementation the
paper authors did got
so uh you know what can we say about
this process so one thing we notice is
the line you know it's less lines of
code typically the line the i heard la
is actually you know pretty terse
um
but also importantly is it's no longer
just c plus you know or python it's it's
any of these languages
um and something else we wanted to do is
understand statistically you know
because you know
we can be accused of cherry picking and
it's essentially you know we are cherry
picking right like we're finding
examples with code that we can you know
that we can implement right there's like
an aspect where it's like it's hard to
separate as a scientist what's like you
you know this is not um
you know double anonymous like this is
like we're we're picking examples that
we think will show our work right but
now we want to do something that's
that's you know
uh that we can't control right so we
roll the dice once
right we take all our 1987 equations and
we we shuffle them and we take the first
hundred and we don't get to do this
again we don't get to keep doing this
until we get numbers that we like we do
this once and we take these 100
equations and then we categorize them
right so
looking at them 53 are just plainly
implementable right another big chunk
are
derivations that aren't meant to be
implemented
right then some of them use you know
partial derivatives and gradients and
some kind of unsupported integration
um some of them have complicated
optimization some control flow and some
other kind of strange operators now
really the derivations are not meant to
be implemented so we should just exclude
those no one's implementing those in any
language
so now maybe we can implement 62 percent
of what we see
and then okay we don't support automatic
differentiation or taking gradients but
you know sometimes those are passed in
as parameters and in optimum you know in
optimization packages they expect you to
you're passing an f so give us also the
gradient of f so we can also do you know
have authors do the same thing with i
heart la or give us the gradient of f is
a parameter so in some sense we can also
you know we could also support that
uh so you know maybe that's how maybe
that's the the unbiased you know
non-cherry-picked applicability of
iheartla
um we also you know did a user study so
we want to know how people use this
uh so we took eight cs phd students who
had you know over six months of
experience implementing linear algebra
and um we gave them three formula and we
said okay you have a preferred
programming environment the one you you
like to use okay you're going to use
that and you're also going to use you
know i heard la
and we counter balanced it so it's like
two in each to two in each condition and
then we gave them you know sequence of
uh of problems simple one just do some
matrix vector multiplication
more complex one you know use summation
and then you know most complex one we
gave them was to build a sparse matrix
um
and you know we got some qualitative
data out of this
um
[Music]
so one thing we got uh you know
liquor five-point liquor scale so
you know people want to please us sure
but you know they they say it's easy to
learn to use i heard la
and a lot of them you know preferred it
to their programming language um and
maybe you know the most
the nicest thing out of this is that
you know people agree that the linear
that really looks like linear algebra in
the papers they see so you know this is
a small study
they're trying to please us sure so
maybe we don't get strong conclusions
out of this um but you know at least
uh
when we look at you know some of the
quantitative data we can we can we can
make you know some statements right so
average completion time they're faster
in their language for the simple problem
they're and that you know is
statistically significant even though
everything's a small number of people
um for the medium case things were
closer and and for the complex case you
know
there wasn't one language wasn't fashion
the other that's we take that as
encouraging right there's the first
exposure to this language and they can
already you know implement things at
approximately the same speed as their
language um
and
so that's you know i think that's that's
encouraging that they can accomplish a
range of tasks in 15 minutes and they
think it looks like conventional math
um
yeah so some limitations so uh i talked
about some the case the kinds of things
that we we don't support right so
there's i don't know mathematical
operators right we don't support
um
uh multiple conditions we actually now
do support this but that's that's you
know that's that's new this is like go
file a github issue if you have
something you you know that's not
supported you want to support you know
derivations right will never support
well i shouldn't say never
it would be nice to not have to switch
languages when writing you know to
switch from i heard late to tech uh you
know maybe we could have a non-compiled
version of i heard la that doesn't
doesn't compile the code but just like
gives you text so you don't have to keep
switching um
you know
the the your your mental mode for
inputting math
um derivatives we don't we don't support
yet um optimization i'll talk about in a
moment and uh and integrals um we don't
support really uh we support some uh not
with implied domains i'll talk about
that right now so we'd like to support
more things you know tensors automatic
differentiation integration optimization
and you know there's a lot of work out
there right on on
automatic differentiation and some
recent work on integration with you know
integrals with
discontinuities um so that's that's just
like file the github issues we'll see
what what people want you know we want
to
we want people to adopt our la
minimization shows up in 10 of the
papers so we wanted to make sure we
weren't going to um
make a grammar that wasn't like
future proof in some sense because we do
want to support more minimization so we
already support a kind of minimization
so we can minimize do some constrained
minimization
and uh
uh we rely on the like in python we rely
on scipy's optimize you know to do this
so in c plus plus we you know we need
something because we don't want to start
implementing a whole bunch of numerical
routines we want to you know just
compile these output environments
so we have some some minimization
support
we also have some uh integration support
for simple integration with
upper and lower bounds
two two styles right some you see you
see people are math rated in both styles
so we support both styles
we want to do more advanced versions of
this and again we just rely on like
what's there in the language
now you know i want to
increased adoption of rla right so more
output languages that's kind of like a
uh you know straightforward um it would
be interesting to embed it into your
tooling so if you're in c plus and you
just want like a bit of i heart la you
know to kind of make it so that you can
do that
julia has a nice macro system so maybe
you could do that there you know
supporting more fields looking at what
they're doing in their equations
large-scale user studies get people to
use this over long periods of time you
know does it make people more productive
uh can we give can we you know can we
give a set of students
or practitioners like an unsolved
research problem with like a measurable
outcome and have some of them use i
heard la and some of them not and see if
they you know improve the state of the
art faster with i heard la
um
automating you know tech di hurley would
let us do the the kind of math picks you
know to tech to to i heard la
also you know papers of the future right
if you imagine a paper of the future
that's using iheartla instead of you
know tech for math then this paper could
compile to a library for improved you
know replicability but also improved
interactivity right like a like a
notebook environment where you can
interact with the equations that are in
there
but also the the the type information
that we have like we know what all the
symbols are and whether you know the
same symbols use in multiple places so
we can do something for readability
right there's some
uh recent work like the scholar five
project
where they
they didn't have i heard la but they
kind of went through with natural
language processing and kind of
heuristics to
to do things like give you a glossary of
symbols and break down you know all of
the uh terms that are used in an
equation right and
um so it'll be really nice to to to make
a writing environment that uses iheartla
that gives that gives
people like them
the information they need to make the
system work you know correctly and on
you know in all ways
but you know just
from our point of view of uh trying to
take existing conventions and meet
people where they are
we'd like to have minimal impact on the
way people write papers right so
something plain text right
uh
again you know the derivations like
here's a bunch of derivations in orange
and then you get to the you know the
formula right so having to handle that
that the out of order symbols
you know this is showing like a symbol
that appears early in the paper depends
on the later symbol which itself depends
on a later symbol and you know we do
this because i guess as authors we we
want to explain the high level thing
first and you know i'll tell you the
details later you'll need to know them
but not yet
and then like i talked about a library
but like what what would a library be
you know like when people write
functions in papers there's often like a
lot of implied parameters when they're
defining functions so
the symbols may appear in different
contexts but that context may be clear
to the reader that the x here the x y
here is a different from an x y there
and finally you know like papers may be
you know multiple sections
uh subsections
which are largely independent
um
right so to conclude all of this
uh
i
i believe that ireland has the potential
to greatly benefit the scientific
ecosystem right the way people write
papers no one wants a replicability
crisis in their field and i think this
can you know this this has a role to
play there
um
i think ireland makes it easy to try new
ideas
uh just write that email and then
execute that email rather than spending
time implementing it um it's pretty easy
to learn because we're just trying to
take what people are already doing
and then finally we want to reduce the
translation loss
uh as ideas move from researchers to
writers to readers to so to implement
her so a graduate student you know
describes their implementation to a
co-author who writes it in latex uh
introduces an error but then someone
else reads the paper and implements it
incorrectly
and that's something that we we don't
wanna that we hope we think we can
reduce
so thank you uh for listening and please
try out i heard la and let us know what
you think
[Applause]
great we have time for questions
yeah
um i wonder if you have explored um
uh maybe a
simplification of like equations or
uh maybe breaking down a very long
equation into the multiple sections for
readability
yeah that's a that's a that's an
interesting idea right um
uh we we have thought that sometimes
like an equation is in a paper and it's
like it's like not exactly a formula
where there's you know something on the
left-hand side equal to something else
but it's close enough you know that
maybe like a reader makes these steps
you know um and
and
like there's you know symbolic algebra
packages you know that may be able to
help right like like factor it uh to
simplify it or solving for in simple
cases i think there's a you know there's
a there's
there's something we could do to
leverage you know work on this you know
some on symbolic algebra and you know
symbolic manipulations to to
um
but we haven't thought you know a lot
about that the that case of like
breaking it down to make it easier to
read yeah yeah
thank you
yeah
so someone also interested in the human
factors of scientific communication i
found your formative study really
interesting because it's this form of
notational survey essentially and it's
about and i'm curious just to hear a
little bit more about your methodology
like you're presented with
1986 equations and you need to
do some kind of semi-structured look
through these things to find out
interesting stuff but how did you
structure that process like there are
lots of aspects of these equations you
could consider summarizing or annotating
um and but but what guided you to decide
that this was an important factor to
look for and therefore would ultimately
inform the design of iheartla yeah yeah
so there are other there are other
attributes that we uh you know
categorized that that didn't even come
up here right like um you know looking
at like who's using superscript and
who's using you know macs and who's
using um
i don't know i i i don't remember them
off the top of my head but it was
basically like a brainstorming process
you know looking at equations and
brainstorming and and saying like what
are all the weird things that show up
right so i think um i think is you know
i think you know young again did a lot
of the hard work here right so he's the
one who went through you know every
siggraph paper and like took screenshots
of every equation and put them in a
giant table you know and uh you know i
think i think it was just it's it's it's
just like did something weird come up
you know like let's make a new category
for it right and then just just try to
enumerate all of you know all the math
that's used um it's it's it's you know
it's error prone potentially right like
if you miscategorize something or maybe
you misunderstand something this
actually came up uh in one iteration
where
like we had examples
and then um
a reviewer would say you know i went to
look in that paper and you got the type
wrong
you know and
and so and so you're making mistakes you
know and so how can i trust like what
you're doing or something like that
right but it's like to actually
implement these correctly like without
you know this is like almost a chicken
and egg thing like if the paper had been
written and i heard away from the you
know in the first place the types would
have been really apparent you know of
every formula but like skimming a paper
reading a paper it's easy to make you
know to get that wrong right and then
potentially to implement it wrong
yeah
so um it seems like you have sort of two
different use cases here
one is um
helping authors
by using the type checking of the of the
generated code to find bugs
in their
writing
and i'm curious if you did any checking
of the equations and all those papers
to find
how many of them have bugs in there
yeah right there's the example you know
early on where it's like a clear typo
yeah right um
yeah um
right it you know some of the questions
we'd like to answer are almost
equivalent to like
implementing every siggraph paper you
know from 2019 like well could we have
this data set like let's just like go
and try to implement it you know and
it's like
you know it's
at some point it's like you know there
that's like too much work you know
that's like that's like too much work to
go through and implement everyone's
thing but some of them we have to like
chase we actually did like have to chase
chase down for quite a while there were
like some papers there's one paper where
we end up finding you know three
different versions of it because it was
really confusing you know to to to
understand like they're reusing um the
the same index you know in a few
summations but the but the length of the
the the the vector was different it was
a different dimension and then like the
description of what that dimension was
supposed to be because it didn't have a
you know upper bound was like in
different places in the paper and was
written out in prose and in a way that
was like
you know
um
uh
kind of a summary right and it it's it's
like took a took a lot of tries to to
make sense of it you know and i hope we
got it right you know but it's
yeah it's it's
like i don't know basically i don't know
how many of these papers you know have
have mistakes
yeah but it's sort of embedded in that
answer there's this interesting question
about why it takes so long to
implement it in in i heart la right
yeah yeah because you know the equation
is written you just start translating it
into your
right syntax right right it's it's it's
the types it's like saying like how many
dimensions is this thing right so going
and finding that thing going and finding
that okay and getting it right it's like
okay this is this is this a scalar is
this a vector and if this is a vector is
it is it the same length as this other
vector is it a different length so it's
like that information ends up being
actually scattered you know pretty you
know pretty far apart in the papers or
right the paper in question was like it
was like it ended up being like a 23
dimensional vector where it had like
camera parameters as six of the
dimensions and it's like well how many
dimensions are in the camera parameters
right so you have to go through like
multiple levels of indirection in the
pros to you know to to finally nail down
what the dimensions of this thing really
is you know right
so
so it is saying before that you know
there are two use cases here one is for
authors and this type checking it seems
like and the other one is
implementing the code
and
they have slightly different goals or
maybe
you know fairly different goals and uh
so i was wondering if you are thinking
about how those goals differ and
what you might do to address them
separately
right right um yeah so some of this is
like
you know sometimes when you write a
paper uh i don't know if i'm revealing
like a secret you know how the sausage
is made right but sometimes like you've
done all this like you you you know
you've coded something and then you've
made changes to it and you've made
changes to it you've made change to it
and then it's time to write the paper
and you want to write something that
like
maybe seems
elegant like it's reasonably elegant and
maybe not like the spaghetti of code
that's like eventually resulted and so
you're trying to like you know come up
with an elegant way to
to to phrase what you've written you
know that still matches what you've
written right and that's like that's
sort of the translation loss you know
thing that i'm getting out there right
but but like implicit in that is the
fact that like you're not working with a
nice clean mathematical you know you're
not like updating your mathematical
formula the whole time and then trying
it you're you're actually in this other
like coding space you know programming
language space where you're making
changes and and then
uh
if you know if if
if you then like write it in you know an
iheartla and compile it and run it and
then you know i guess you could check if
you got the same thing as as you know
what you would written or not uh in you
know your spaghetti code version of it
but like there's a there's another you
know world i guess in which
you did i heard late played a role in
the in all of the experiments right and
that's like if that's like that's like a
different thing right that's like
oh if if if we could make it so the you
know the
the email or the the blackboards you
know were were like authoritative you
know the whole time that would like that
is a change to how people work right so
i guess i'm trying to have my cake and
eat it too i'm trying to say we don't
want to change how you work we just want
to like make things work better but like
i really do want to change how you work
you know
yeah all right i think we're out of time
but thank you so much
thank you for having me